lopez again
kicks it to the corner on a cut to beale
the two
does soda tice gets it to tatum passed
up the three takes it in there for two
and gets to
no foul that just gave them a free
timeout to draw up a play right now
the wizards do have one timeout
remaining murray hachimora is in the
game now to guard tice
richard is in tatum having trouble
getting it in
it's richard with the ball back to tatum
eight seconds to go tatum spins tatum
puts it up and in with 4.7
and the wizards down by one in the final
timeout
being used here by scott brooks
good job attacking the glass i mean that
is
two big plays he has made down the
stretch
for the celtics you already saw the
drive with the finish to the left on the
baseline
and then to have the ability to get this
isolation great call by brad stevens
making him the inbounder to get this
position and then being able to split
ruin mid-air
and brad the finish on the other side 31
to get the ball mike he does
[Music]
excellent double team he puts up a shot
anyway and the celtics
escape 111 to 110.
well the celtics decided to trap beal
out of the corner
they had nowhere to go
[Music]
jason tatum was a big